facebook are you on this thing it was uh
it was a small
website created by this guy mark
zuckerberg
who wanted to meet girls basically about
25 years ago
he created this thing it became sort of
the giant behemoth
of all time next to google let's say and
now it's not just that they can just
delete your account when they want or
they can
limit who sees your account or that they
can shadow ban you and the series of
other things that you guys know about
now they're actually uh going to have a
button
the button is popping up i guess they're
rolling it out in phases although now
people are pushing back so we'll see
what happens
a button so that you'll be able to warn
facebook if you know about people who
are becoming extremists and by
extremists they mean
basically anyone who's not woke these
are images
from disclose dot tv
and uh let's pull these images up are
you concerned that someone you know is
becoming an extremist
we care about preventing extremism on
facebook
others in your situation have received
confidential support
how you can help and then get support or
close and then uh here's the other one
so carl i'm not sure who carl is i guess
carl works for
me carl you may have been exposed to
harmful extremist content recently
violent groups try to manipulate your
anger and disappointment
you can take action now to protect
yourself and others
now of course because i have a
thoughtful bright
insightful audience you guys already get
what this is about this has nothing to
do
with violent and hateful content because
if it was about violent
content let's say direct calls for
violence direct calls for terrorism
something like that
it would be taken off facebook
immediately but what they're really
doing are you concerned that someone you
know is becoming an extremist what they
mean
really by that is are you concerned that
someone you know might be watching
ben shapiro he talks fast and he says
conservative things
or stephen crowder or dave rubin or
jordan peterson
or something like that i guarantee you
that none of these warnings are being
put
on any woke site those are the real
extremists the ones that are
pushing racism back into the system the
ones that are burning down cities and
defunding the police
and attacking stores and rampaging
through san francisco
and everything else that they're doing
attacking federal buildings in portland
so when they say are you concerned that
someone you know is becoming extremist
what they're saying is are you concerned
that someone
you know might be not woke are you
concerned that someone you know might
become a sensible conservative
are you concerned that someone you know
may not uh fully accept
all of the blue and odd narrative that's
being forced down everyone's throat
completely i don't like you facebook
you're not good you're not good bad
facebook is bad and the fact that
they're now like i mean this is this is
gen
genuinely this is sort of like out of
communism 101 like
rat on your neighbors this is very
reminiscent actually
of remember at the beginning of lockdown
like when people were calling the cops
on there and my neighbors were in the
backyard
they were playing music they had people
over actually a couple doors down we
have some friends that had a baby and
then they had a baby shower
and the cut somebody ratted on them and
the cops came and the cops actually
apologized to them but they said we have
to
we have to actually come here but this
idea will be ratting on each other for
when we get together in real life and
we'll be ratting
on our friends who might be extremists
even though by extremists you probably
mean
sane i mean for example i am a radical
right-wing freedom extremist
i believe in freedom i believe in
liberty i believe that you can make the
choices
for yourself i can make the choices for
myself and we'll negotiate how to go
forward with the society
that's very scary to the people that
want to control you
so thus i am a radical right-wing
extremist
so i assume that these warnings are
going all over your facebook pages
if uh if you follow me